I just realized I love Game of Thrones and
I hate spoilers, yet here I am reading a script
for season 6 game of thrones spoilers.
I need to re-evaluate my life choices.
Ready for some Game of Thrones season six
spoilers?
“You know nothing…
Jon Snow.”
No, well too bad.
The season finale confirmed the long-held
fan theory that Jon Snow has Targaryen blood.
Now, the big questions looming over the newly
crowned King in the North are if, when, and
how he and his biological aunt, Daenerys Targaryen,
will learn about their connection, and if
makes them friends...or foes.
But could Dany's trusty sidekick be the one
to ultimately bring the family together?
Here's how Jorah Mormont will unite Daenerys
and Jon Snow in Game of Thrones...
Shades of Greyscale
The last glimpse we got of Jorah came when
Daenerys sent him away on horseback to find
a cure for his case of Greyscale.
Thanks to Princess Shireen Baratheon, we know
that a cure must exist for the disease, since
she had it as a baby and was healed.
Details on who or what saved her back then
aren't clear, but Jorah is resourceful enough
to find out.
Well, let’s hope so.
Maybe he'll return to Qarth and consult with
Quaithe, the mysterious, masked shadowbinder
who's both a prophet and good with protective
body paint.
She's one of the characters missing from Season
6, and she's due for a comeback.
Or perhaps Ser Jorah will run into Melisandre
the Red Witch and strike a deal–after all,
she's a free agent now, and a place in Dany's
kingdom would likely be a welcome opportunity.
I mean, she’s welcome to my kingdom at least
anytime.
I don’t enven care if she is old and stuff,
wait I do.
Family reunion
Fans loved meeting Lady Lyanna Mormont, the
pint-sized leader of Bear Island.
Her voice bends the will of even the toughest
leaders in the North, and she helped Jon Snow
claim his throne at Winterfell.
“I don’t care if he is a bastard.
Ned Stark’s blood runs through his veins.
He’s my king from this day until his last
day.”
She also just so happens to be Jorah's first
cousin.
The former Lord of Bear Island has kept away
from his home since being exiled, but maybe
it's time to return home and atone for his
crimes, starting with a visit to Lady Lyanna
so he can plead for mercy.
That rekindled connection with Lyanna would
certainly get the ball rolling on introducing
his Queen to the King in the North.
Dragon lover
Now that she's left her lover Daario Naharis
to babysit the people of Meereen, Daenerys
is single—and ready to mingle.
“Does that mean you are now eligible.”
“Yes, I am eligible.
I’m single and I want to mingle.”
Jorah, meanwhile, has admitted his true feelings
for her:
“I love you.
I will always love you.”
Awkward.
Daenerys has already indicated that she plans
to make her next marriage a strategic one
that helps unite her with her one true love:
the Iron Throne.
So romantic...
Given the potential of the Mormont name to
help secure her audience with key leaders
in the North, a marriage could fulfill both
their hearts' desires and be good for politics.
Hey it could happen!
A Song of Ice and Fire
Let's not forget that Daenerys isn't the only
Targaryen who needs allies for the war ahead.
After all, winter has finally come to the
North, and the Night King could bring it everywhere
else.
Dany's fire-breathing dragons could be just
what Snow needs to defeat the icy undead.
“Dracarus.”
Plus, Dany already has an old friend of Jon's
on board: Theon Greyjoy.
Jorah, with the influence of Lyanna and possibly
even Davos Seaworth, could finally bring the
Targaryen family together again to sing their
song of ice and fire.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
role you think Ser Jorah will play...